how's the gum resin welcome back don't
educate him second son infamous so we
need to investigate the crime scene away
how are we gonna do that although what's
the use of having smoke powers if you're
not gonna use them suck up that [ __ ]
okay so they left is weird stuff what
does that mean does that mean um alright
this has all right I guess it's a victim
definitely the work of a conduit
it's very showy okay I need you to take
a couple pictures of the crime scene and
send them to me anything that might give
us a lead all right but first let me
take a lead - selfie no no all right
well how about this a promise kept
that's a good picture right the drugs is
the lead oh there's a man mister the
dead man all right there's your wounds
what kind of power did this fire blaster
hopefully lasers ooh about flesh-eating
death gaze yeah I wouldn't mind
absorbing a little flesh-eating death
gaze right
Dolson even if the guy who did this is a
prime conduit we still don't know what
this power transfer thing's even gonna
work well you know what if it does my
first victim it's gonna be the guy who
came up with the name banner man oh
really need to let that go
Red's I'm hearing sirens man yeah let me
check before you pay just cordoned off
the area I've won the Seattle PD to stay
away past me the conduit I'll check it
out go to the new crime scene there's a
new crime scene okay I got a convoy of
dupes heading to the scene
I want to steer clear enough all right
time to investigate and broker yes well
this conduit sure got a certain style
kind of Nouveau sick I'm never sick nice
now let me guess face and wounds he just
what hey this is a perm
he just wants some Nate some Craig guy
picks whatever guy wounds no need I've
got a hit on the face guys our drug
dealer rap sheets a mile long look
around for a stash a stash what kind of
things this - a mustache a dolphin's -
you should have nice ass - now I get it
there's a sniper but I wanted this Hale
me I come in peace don't you bail me
okay okay one of you I mean pinky lasers
God so uncool oh I see where he went
it's time to play chemical yeah Jesus
spice come on
he's like sanic yeah I see man that was
sandy no he ran fast like like really
really fast conduit fast man screw
flesh-eating death gay don't like that
funny thing that you go for every shot
you could see the neon sign behind him
dim a little power source Neon Bible is
some power sign Wow
it's like my spirit animal except - see
what this guy can do man like lasers or
something I'm telling you it would be
great to have a one-two punch like that
and smoke when I get to Agustin what are
we looking for you're exactly breast
does anyone really know why don't we get
here well I sticker a sure thing this
place tells us Garnier pristine girl up
girls stuff like the name Brent burned
into the wall and girly handwriting and
it is definitely the best smelling
Assassin's den you could ever be in he
just wants me to take photos photos of
her panties so there you go you're
welcome perv okay oh you never know
no and these boots I couldn't fit in
them those are women's shoes yeah
they're like size negative
[Laughter]
only girls read this book of had really
Jane Eyre is like the female Catcher in
the Rye and then Brent of course my
favorite
god I love brain relax I'm looking
really there's more I guess this counts
is interesting what is the other half of
the
all right how does physics work that is
a long shot that is a very long shot
there is a longer shot in this you know
if I had smoke and lasers I could like
put on light shows in our living room
I'd be putting your powers I'd be the
coolest guy at the rave parties to stop
okay can I wear them please stop all
right you know I'm going back now you
never know smoke and then boobs boobs
smoke genius she did warning them in
hairdressing smoke yeah our girls
definitely got a thing against drug
dealers it's weird though man if she's
just telling drug dealers then why did
the news reports make it sound like
she's picking off random victims like it
could be anybody well you'd think the
DUP would want people to know the
killings weren't random that if you're
not a drug dealer you're not in danger
I'm sure bring the panic level down
their job is to control the panic now
they want to scare us
fear is good am i right almost there
smooth sailing to the ocean of their
family but there's a bunch of heavily
armed dudes here looks like a drug deals
going down on you but it is the duty of
every citizen to step up when they
witness a crime in progress so now you
do want me killing people with my powers
I kill them just rough them up scare him
a little and destroy their stash destroy
their stashes high five hey man have
five come on just one high five please
oh god what is this you don't mind it
well then I'm not gonna stop you say
goodbye to your stashes are you scared
now
well they have guns what I have to kill
them think you're gonna get away I shoot
you at the pizzas girl
oh yeah I can smoke - Jesus forgot
genius parents accent oh you should see
this manse
Wow crazy is a tagger she's pretty damn
good one too
somewhere a vortex Bathurst
oh mama pull the bottle Brent Brent
Brent Brent
oh look Brent it's always Brent with
this girl oh my god it says Brent over
everywhere even here since Brent
I got another Brent wow there must be a
lot of Brent's out there and then we
have the birds the backhand selfie haha
telling you man this is gonna work oh
I'll suck alright that must be Brent she
sets a lovely altar it's actually kind
of touching yeah well there's good
touching and bad touching what are we
done here
and now we come to the highlight of the
tour
oh it's sense of it rest in peace Brent
okay so the girl stops off for takeout
comes here to sit with neon Brent to
tell them all about her day while she
chowder's down you know olaf's has a
location on Alaskan Way hey if I had
neon powers and a chowder Jones that's
where I'd hang I'm on my way
how are you doing the young Brent big
fine
high five yeah neon Brent - my favorite
neon brand - the bears neon Brenda is
wearing me inside his chest don't ask me
how that works just does very well to
the next station high five alright
you're pretending that you don't see me
you're racist I want to blow this tower
up for funsies
didn't work ah I didn't check oops
miss click sorry say no to narcotics I
wonder how much time they spent make it
while making this game to look for drug
puns anti-drug pens I'm trying ok place
to hide my fuse boxes metal really
hopeless stylin melegari style
[Music]
this way to the lawn it's been like five
seconds god I think I don't have a life
Wow take some cash up those dealers are
you talking about
okay Oh stealing that power
haha I guess your past
I'm a living disco ball amazing these
powers Delsin concentrate happening get
away I got this now Jesus Christ this
colors oh my god sorry sorry I left mate
just don't mind me just being sanic
nothing ain't nothing wrong with that
oh damn that's usefully speech no one
told me I had to running Jesus I don't
know what you're talking about
did she think she leaves these giant
neon trail how much she doesn't use it
maybe then I wouldn't find her
Oh God okay that's what they all say but
you will have to learn how to be over
that I'm not a horse not a horse
last time I checked that lady though
it's been a while to be on it where the
fudge cake there we go finally
high-five come on high-five everyone's
rejected me so far now you got damn
[Music]
every time they never want to join my
shoes are the name she means the shell
pill okay but I'm Sanok so we're gonna
have a problem there I'll drain the neon
disco let's choose for her bad news I
need to I need to drain all the neon
signs guarding that's the way I like it
that's - ow that's the way uh-huh uh-huh
I like ya now have the killer I have
enough disco in me to shake them to the
boobies I don't know what I said okay
high five
just follow the pink line and you'll be
fine stop there we go
you and your stupid jacket it's not 2004
oh god what are we doing are we having a
disco off I think so
a very rare sight I don't know I'm just
melting their face okay got it
there's a little girl I never thought
it'd be me and I'd be one of them
my powers were a surprise
my parents turned me in my parents they
knew what the government would do to
people like me and they did it anyway I
didn't know what to do what my brother
Brent just grabbed our coats
who wants a dash of Brent one
those were hard days ha Street moving
from city to city no comfort anywhere
that's how I met some dealers and man
the drugs drugs war heaven
all right what happened to the ng dragon
pie hello but then we always want
anymore no never no always we're looking
for a fix
and when you lose your stash what do you
think someone stole it from you the
drugs the dealers they know the
government picked me up easy enough
after that what it wasn't a regular jail
they trained me to shoot Tommy how to
kill I thought you already knew crash I
escaped with all those skills everything
I needed to set things right
I promise every dealer I find I'm gonna
burn your name in the chest no one else
it's gonna suffer like we did no brother
nobody else what about Walter White
you'd be mad bad good buddy come on oh
whoa hey you did good I know just where
to put the filth like this somewhere
where Augustine won't find her and she
won't be hurting anybody no no no she's
just killing drug dealers man yeah no
but he'll Nelson murdering drug dealers
you think I'm doing to the dup what you
have to to save the Acoma shhhhhh back
home she stays free no no way look just
because you have the same affliction not
gift affliction doesn't mean that we're
gonna pick up every little piece of
trash we find oh I'm never going to
abandon you alright
not ever this one goes in a cage
I get to choose I have two tubes a we
gonna corrupt fetch we go on a car
repair mold her to be remorseless killer
and unleash her on the anti conduit
activist I mean that doesn't sound bad
but it has red all over it says I am
redeemed fetch I'm like teach her
self-control by working together to
dismantle Seattle's illegal drug trade I
want to pick this one
you know I want to pick this one but in
this game it seems like you have to
commit you know that we're gonna go me
that one responsibility yeah cuz
responsibilities not exactly something
you excel in okay
fine I'm here for the tribe at the
Holland bioterrorist conduit
did she just con con you ins normally
cool he's just today yeah
but I thought we would disco of dancing
off all right can I have to end that
episode there bros if you liked and
enjoyed and please leave a like it helps
me out a lot it makes me do a backflip
every time you do it try it
sorry I had wait wait until the video is
done got it anyway
thanks for hanging out with me today
breath and as always stay awesome bros